-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
It's time to play "Password."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Let's meet our contestants.
To my left,
she's the Tony-nominated star
of the new play,
"POTUS: Or, Behind Every Great
Dumbass, There Are Seven
Women Trying to Keep Him Alive."
Say hello to the Rachel Dratch!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tony!
Rachel, your partner
this evening is the host
of NBC's "The Tonight Show"
and Saugerties' sweetheart,
Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Your first opponent is from our
very own Roots, Mr. Questlove.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And, Quest, your partner can be
seen in season four
of "Stranger Things,"
which premieres this Friday
on Netflix.
It's Sadie Sink!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Sadie Sink!
Yeah!
-Okay.
The rules are very simple.
-They are.
-I will give each of you
a password, and you're
to give a one-word clue
to your partner
to guess that password.
-Yep.
-The team with the most points
after four words wins.
-Okay.
-Any questions?
-Yeah. Well --
-Okay. Let's start.
[ Laughter ]
Jimmy and Questlove...
-Yes?
-...the password is "margarita."
-Questlove,
we're gonna start with you.
-[ Sighs ]
Ah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm a throw out...salt.
I did this is on purpose.
-Pepper?
[ Laughter ]
-Go ahead.
-Okay. So --
-So, he said "salt."
-Well 'cause I knew she wouldn't
know my reference.
I said the obvious one.
-Ready?
Colada.
-What?
-Word. All right.
-All right.
-Wait, wait. She didn't --
-Okay, let her guess.
-Salt...
Colada.
[ Laughter ]
-Margarita?
-Whoa!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh, my God!
-It's not fair.
I'm 20 years old.
-I know, I know.
-That's how you play it!
-I wanted to say Jimmy Buffett
but I didn't know if you --
-That's how you do it!
-Dang!
-Sully and Denise, come on!
-Got her thinking
about cocktails.
-That's my drink of choice.
-Oh, my God.
-Damn, okay.
-Oh, my goodness.
Next clue goes
to Sadie and Rachel.
-Okay.
-The password is "Jacuzzi."
-Gosh, Rachel, you're up first.
-Oh, I'm up first. Okay.
-Good luck.
-Oh, um...
Um...Whirlpool.
[ Laughter ]
-Whirlpool.
Whirlpool.
[ Laughter ]
Dishwasher?
-Ooh.
[ Laughter ]
-That was good.
-No colada.
[ Laughter ]
-Close, but no cigar.
-Okay.
I think it's two words.
I'm just gonna say "tub."
-Tub.
Whirlpool, tub.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Bath?
-I'm gonna do an inside...
-Oh, you got it.
-...inside job here.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Colada.
-Hernandez.
-Yes.
-Uh...uh...
But I think it's two words.
But wait, we'll see.
-Ooh!
-It's a...Jacuzzi?
-Yeah!
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my!
-I was gonna say "sauna"
after that.
-Barbara Hernandez!
Barbara Hernandez!
-I'm sorry.
-Hot tub because --
-Because it's an old sketch
we did.
-Yeah. We would sit --
-We were in a hot tub.
-You and Will were the creepy
people -- "lov-ahs"
-And you were in the Jacuzzi
with us.
With Barbara Hernandez.
-"My friend,
Barbara Hernandez."
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy and Questlove,
the next clues are for you.
-Okay.
-The password is "puddle."
-Jim, won't you start us off?
-Jim.
[ Laughter ]
Oh.
-[ British accent ] Muddy.
-[ Chortles ]
[ Laughter ]
Muddy.
-Oh, my God.
-Muddy.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
Uh, shoot.
Muddy?
-Muddy.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
-[ British accent ] Galoshes.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good, that's good.
Sadie.
[ Laughter ]
-You heard what she said, right?
-Galoshes.
-Right.
Water.
-Umbrella.
-Ooh.
Same family.
4 points if you get this one.
-Mm-hmm.
-It's your game, Jim.
-Yeah, I know.
Thank you.
-Jim.
[ Laughter ]
-Um...
Rain.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, uh...
puddle?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
-Damn.
-Oh, my goodness!
-Whoo!
Unbelievable!
-That was good.
-13-0.
-Blowout.
-Final clue goes
to Sadie and Rachel.
-All right.
-The password is "popsicle."
-Okay. Sadie,
we're gonna start with you.
There you go.
-How many points is this?
-How many points?
-This is for 1 billion points.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Great.
We can come back.
-Get the whole game.
1 billion points.
-Ice cream.
Oh, wait.
[ Laughter ]
It's one, it's one.
-Yeah, we're gonna say --
-Yeah, we're gonna say
it's hyphenated.
-You guys are gonna win anyway.
-Iced cream.
-Ice cream.
Trip.
[ Laughter ]
-Drip?
-Trip?
-No.
-You thought that she --
You thought she was doing --
-Nah, nah, nah!
Just go ahead, man.
[ Laughter ]
Trip?
-You better get this one now.
-Cyclone.
-Oh.
-Ooh.
-Cyclone...
Popsicle?
-Yes!
[ Ding! ]
-Ah!
-What is going on?
Are we -- come on.
-Oh, my God.
-This is what happens.
-Oh, my God --
1,000,000,013 points.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to Rachel Dratch,
Sadie Sink, Questlove.
We're talking to Rachel
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪